the person sitting in your very seats is
a liar we're all liars on a given day
studies show that you may be lied to
anywhere from 10 to 200 times now
granted many of those are white laws but
in another study it showed that
strangers lied three times within the
first 10 minutes of meeting each other
we lie more to strangers than we lie to
coworkers extroverts lie more than
introverts men lie eight times more
about themselves and they do other
people women lie more to protect other
people if you're in an average married
couple you're gonna lie to your spouse
in 1 out of every 10 interactions now
you may think that's bad if you're
unmarried that number drops to 3 they're
good liars and they're bad liars they're
no real original liars we all make the
same mistakes we all use the same
techniques studies show that people who
are over determined in their denial will
resort to formal rather than informal
language I want you to listen to me I'm
gonna say this again I did not have
sexual relations with that woman miss
Lewinsky
we also heard distancing language that
woman we know that Liars will
unconsciously distance themselves from
their subject using language as their
tool
ask a deceptive person to tell their
story they're gonna pepper it with way
too much detail in all kinds of
irrelevant places we all do the same
thing we rehearse our words but we
rarely rehearse our gestures we say yes
we shake our heads no we tell very
convincing stories we slightly shrug our
shoulders we commit terrible crimes and
we smile at the delight and getting away
with it
now that Smile is known in the trade as
duping delight we know Liars will shift
their blink rate point their feet
towards an exit
they will take barrier objects and put
them between themselves and the person
that's interviewing them they'll alter
their vocal tone often making their
vocal tone much lower now here's the
deal these behaviors are just behaviors
they're not proof of deception they're
red flags they don't mean anything in
and of themselves but when you see
clusters of them that's your signal